école dans la forêt une révolution verte
point d'interrogation documentaire
signal Charlotte Rouxel old drap un film
qui nous présente plutôt favorablement
il faut bien le dire un modèle d'école
assez nouveau original et qui elle
mérite de sensibiliser dès le plus jeune
âge aux enjeux environnementaux est-ce
pour autant un modèle d'avenir on va se
poser la question avec nos invités
Jacques Grosperrin bienvenu vous êtes
sénateur LR du Doubs membre de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication je précise aussi
que vous êtes professeur agrégé
d'éducation physique et docteur en
sciences de l'éducation Moïna Fauchier
de la ville bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes journaliste co-auteur du livre
l'enfant dans la nature avec Matthieu
cheyrroz éditions Fayard Matthieu
Chereau que l'on voit très régulièrement
dans le documentaire et vous êtes aussi
co-auteur avec Christelle Ferjoux de ce
livre emmener les enfants dehors aux
éditions Robert Laffont enfin vous êtes
cofondatrice de l'association La
fabrique des communs pédagogiques
Sylvain Wagnon bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes historien professeur en
sciences de l'éducation à l'Université
de Montpellier coauteur du livre l'école
don et avec la nature la révolution
pédagogique du 21e siècle avec Corinne
Martel aux éditions ESF Sciences
Humaines vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'un
autre livre c'est celui-ci les
pédagogies alternatives mieux les
connaître pour en tirer le meilleur aux
hélices enfin Laura Nicolas bienvenue
vous êtes enseignante chercheur en
sciences de l'éducation à l'Université
Paris-Est Créteil vous avez créé un site
internet intitulé Ma Petite Forêt
notamment pour guider vers un
enseignement en extérieur dans la nature
et vous êtes aussi responsable de la
formation l'école du dehors les
présentations sont faites merci à vous
quatre d'être là la première question on
remarque qui nous viennent quand on
regarde ce documentaire c'est qu'il
semble impossible de dupliquer ce modèle
que ça ne peut marcher que lorsqu'on vit
dans un cadre naturel très privilégié
que en gros ça pourrait être l'affaire
de quelques dizaines de communes en
France grand maximum est-ce qu'on se
trompe Moïna fauché de la vigne est-ce
qu'en fait ce serait un modèle plus le
câble contre le pense
complètement
beaucoup plus duplicable que que ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer et notamment au
Danemark où c'est très développé en
Matthieu Giraud en parle où il y a 20%
des écoles maternelles qui sont des
écoles en forêt la plupart de ces écoles
en forêt sont aussi des écoles en ville
parce que c'est là où les parents
ressemblent que leurs enfants ont le
plus besoin d'être au quotidien en
contact avec la nature et dehors j'ai
agropère qu'on aille vous pensez en
gardant ce film est-ce que vous est dit
c'est vrai qu'après tout ça pourrait se
faire en tout cas dans beaucoup plus
d'endroits peut-être pas partout mais
que on pourrait le développer je crois
que toutes les pédagogies alternatives
sont intéressantes et moi j'ai trouvé
que c'est un film très intéressant et
d'autant plus que ça se situe à l'île de
Ré un cadre un peu particulier un
microclimat aussi je crois que non alors
le fait de pouvoir le dupliquer dans
d'autres régions départements villes de
France
c'est peut-être un peu compliqué on y
viendra peut-être après un coup ça on y
viendra c'est vrai parce que là on voit
que c'est une école avec 11 enfants donc
il faut des moyens mais l'éducation d'un
coup elle a pas de prix on dit souvent
mais je crois que c'est en tout cas
quelque chose qui est intéressant et qui
doit le faire réfléchir et même si on
fait pas l'école à la forêt sous une
forme institutionnelle on peut en tout
cas tirer beaucoup de d'anciennement de
ce que de ce qu'on a vu dans le film au
quotidien pour les professeurs des
écoles dans leur pratique quotidiennes
100% en extérieur on a j'ai regardé plus
de 2 millions d'élèves en école
maternelle en France est-ce que ça
semble duplicable à cette échelle là
d'après vous l'aura Nicolas
alors j'aime bien j'aime bien l'idée
qu'il n'y a pas une école du dehors
qu'il y a des contextes des personnes
des porteurs de projets des enseignants
et que et des pratiques pédagogiques
c'est pas aussi homogène qu'on pourrait
le penser et aussi le caractère
duplicable à mon avis il vient de cet
hétérogénéité possible c'est à dire ce
qu'on voit se faire à l'île de Ré peut
se faire ailleurs dans le doux se fait
ailleurs en forêt de Sologne peut se
faire ailleurs vous êtes d'accord c'est
une réunion parce que je suis un peu
tonnée tout le monde a l'air d'accord
pourtant quand on regarde qu'on est
simple citoyen ou parents aussi d'élèves
on se dit mais c'est juste pas possible
il faut un cadre naturel très
particulier il faut une météo quand même
particulière on laisse les enfants
dehors toute la journée quand avez-vous
pensé
qui nous montre quelque chose d'assez
singulier bon c'est l'île de Ré etc dans
un écosystème particulier avec des
enfants ils sont extrêmement peu
nombreux donc il y a le côté singulier
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que la
question de développer en tout cas cette
école dehors doit passer par l'école
publique parce que ça je crois que c'est
un des points importants si on veut
vraiment diffuser ça et ça a été dit
aussi sur la formation des enseignants
enfin etc qui doit être fait ça c'est un
élément évidemment de développement
extrêmement fort et puis il y a aussi
cette idée de voir la différence de
forme je dirais de forme d'école mais
aussi forme des méthodes parce que c'est
vrai que l'enjeu il est pas simplement
de diviser le rural et l'urbain de voir
que la extrême majorité des gens on vit
en ville et c'est une réalité et que
l'école dehors peut avoir une réalité en
ville bien sûr c'est pas une forêt
school c'est pas en plein milieu d'une
forêt il faut pas non plus c'est une
vraie question ça peut être au bord du
périphérique vous êtes d'accord avec moi
tout à fait mais ça peut être ça mais je
dirais quand même pour présenter c'est
que il faut voir que par exemple la
végétalisation des cours de récréation
et est une un mouvement extrêmement fort
par la loi aussi mais aussi une volonté
des collectivités locales ça ça change
véritablement parce que ça veut dire
qu'on peut faire aussi l'école dehors à
l'intérieur de l'école mais c'est
surtout cette question de reconnecter
aussi à la nature et d'avoir un autre
regard mais vous me dites au bord du
périph avec 30 élèves par classe moi une
affoché de tout Oui 30 élèves par classe
ça se fait parce que la ce que ce dont
parlait Laura sur sur l'école publique
et la classe dehors donc par exemple ce
que c'est Christelle faire joue elle a
commencé ça il y a une dizaine d'années
déjà dans les Deux-Sèvres elle était
dans une école tout à fait normale avec
une classe tout à fait normale avec 30
élèves avec une ATSEM ou pas d'absm
enfin et c'est tout à fait possible de
le faire c'est pas à 100% du temps mais
c'est même pas la question parce que
Danemark ce qu'on considère comme les
écoles en forêt ils le font pas tous à
100% du temps en Allemagne non plus
c'est
plusieurs heures par jour quoi mais mais
en France par exemple souvent c'est une
fois par semaine une demi-journée par
semaine par exemple et c'est avec une
classe de 30 élèves et c'est tout à fait
faisable et à côté du périph
effectivement il y a des par exemple il
y a une école à Paris qui est pas loin
du périph ils ont refait la cour de
récréation qui est maintenant ils
analyse des visites pour les autres
collectivités pour voir comment c'est
comment on peut faire évoluer les cours
de récréation et c'est des espaces qui
sont vraiment intéressants maintenant
notamment pour faire classe dehors et en
plus c'est un espace qui est plus adapté
pour les enfants et pour le climat
scolaire donc c'est aussi c'est
intéressant et on parle bien d'école
maternelle où ça va ça peut aller
au-delà en terme de niveau bien sûr ça
peut aller au-delà de la maternelle ça
peut aller c'est vrai bon vous avez
totalement raison c'est vrai qu'on voit
bien que maternelle c'est quelque chose
de plus aisé parce que justement déjà
dans notre histoire la maternelle a
toujours tenté en tout cas de de
permettre aux enfants d'être en lien
plus avec la nature dans le primaire
aussi parce qu'il faut quand même aussi
voir que l'enseignant est seul dans sa
classe donc il le fait l'ensemble c'est
vrai que dans le secondaire il y a des
obstacles il y a des des contraintes
mais il y a aussi de fortes perspectives
c'est même là d'ailleurs que l'enjeu va
se jouer parce que c'est évidemment
cette division en discipline scolaire
qui existe justement la cour de
récréation végétalisée peut permettre
justement aussi aux enseignants de
repenser aussi leur renseignement propre
sans aller très très loin je crois qu'il
faut aussi voir le côté très pragmatique
de cette école dehors c'est tout n'est
pas l'île de Ré clairement ça il faut
pas l'oublier oui il y a également des
programmes alors après certains vont me
dire ici il y a des grands spécialistes
donc ils peuvent permettre pas de de les
contrarié mais par rapport à cela il y a
des programmes et il faut pas toujours
s'appuyer ou en tout cas sur retrancher
derrière les programmes mais c'est vrai
que on le voit dans les jardins
d'enfants à Paris d'ailleurs le principe
des jardins d'enfants pédagogique à
Paris ou en Alsace ou ailleurs ça
ressemble un petit peu à ce qu'on voit
dans cette école buissonnière c'est que
ça va tant qu'on a un programme un peu
léger mais dès qu'on arrive maternelle
c'est un vrai anciennement ce qu'on peut
regretter c'est que justement les
professeurs des écoles n'est pas assez
de formation en tout cas spécialisée par
rapport à cette anciennement là parce
que c'est une vraie c'est un vrai
anciennement important parce qu'on dit
souvent dans les premières années de la
vie c'est là où tout se fait donc le
fait de se retrouver ce côté socialisant
en réalité ce sont que des prétextes des
projets pour pouvoir discuter échanger
s'affirmer et puis grandir tout
simplement donc moi je regrette qu'une
chose c'est que la loi sur sur l'école
la loi de 2019 et supprimer en quelque
sorte parce qu'on il y a un moratoire
pour ses jardins d'enfants donc en 2019
jusqu'en 2024 et nous en ce moment on
essaie de faire en sorte que ces
expérimentations là ces écoles ces
jardins d'enfants pédagogiques etc
puisse exister parce que ça enrichit
tout l'ensemble comme ça a été justement
à l'instant là ça enrichit tout
l'ensemble de de l'enseignement et du
fonctionnement pédagogique en France
j'ai une question qui va peut-être vous
déranger et Laura Nicolas je vais vous
la poser mais est-ce que c'est une
demande une attente qui vient des
parents plus que des enfants à un moment
donné dans le documentaire c'est juste
suggérer qu'il y a un enfant qui demande
à revenir dans le cursus un peu normal
l'école classique et c'est vrai que ça
interroge parce que ça va très vite dans
le documentaire mais on entend qu'un
enfant a envie de revenir dans l'école
classique est-ce que quelque part c'est
pas une attente des nouvelle génération
2023 plus que des enfants eux-mêmes
est-ce qu'ils ont vraiment envie de
rester dehors toute la journée vraiment
c'est une question c'est une question
qui est très intéressante elle me parle
beaucoup parce que nous-mêmes en accueil
péri extrascolaire on accueille beaucoup
de familles effectivement quand on a les
parents motivés qui font équipe avec
avec les enseignants ça arrive ça fait
ça fait vraiment se réaliser l'école
dehors les enfants qu'en est-il j'allais
dire de manière quasi unilatérale on a
des enfants qui ont envie et on commence
à avoir des retours d'enfants qui ont
vécu l'école dehors souvent en
maternelle on parlait de cette
possibilité plus étendue et qui en
sixième par exemple vont revenir en
classe fermée donc on a ces doubles
expériences ou soit ils ont vraiment
apprécié ça en amont et sont déçus de
rentrer à l'école du dedans mais je
pense que sur la question des enfants
comme celle des parents il faut à mon
sens éviter d'opposer le dedans au
dehors on est sur une véritable
articulation donc même si on a des
enfants qui peuvent parce qu'ils sont
pas habitués
avoir commencé à avoir froid à être
fatigué le fait de cet articulation du
dedans dehors l'articulation entre trois
lieux le lieu de la cour de récréation
que j'avais souvent soit un plan B c'est
vraiment on peut pas aller dehors parce
que on le chemin est trop loin le milieu
de proximité qui va être le lieu de la
classe de horreur proche et puis de
temps en temps on y articule avec une
sortie à la forêt un petit peu plus loin
c'est trois lieux là font que enfant et
parents finissent par y trouver leur
compte
pour suivre justement je m'intéresse un
pédagogue belge d'éducation nouvelle au
début du 20e siècle qui disait la classe
c'est quand il pleut ça veut dire pour
lui l'idée est de dire il y a une
complémentarité extrêmement forte s'agit
pas de sortir et là je crois qu'on
touche un point aussi que le
documentaire aborde c'est que c'est pas
parce qu'on sort qu'on va faire
différemment aussi et ça c'est peut-être
une des discussions qu'on peut avoir
parce que si on sort pour faire la même
chose qu'à l'intérieur c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose il sert ça pas
d'intérêt faut le dire clairement la
salle de classe est un lieu
d'apprentissage extrêmement fort et et
[Musique]
quand j'ai créé l'école j'avais pas
envie d'avoir une école que pour les
riches pour moi c'était vraiment
important d'avoir un prix abordable pour
tout le monde donc j'ai fixé un prix à
275 euros sur 10 mois on rentre pas trop
dans nos frais l'année prochaine on va
faire trois différents tarifs selon le
quotient familial ça va aller de 200 à
260 euros
de 100 à 260 euros par mois c'est
évidemment pas possible pour des
millions de parents en France est-ce que
pardon pour la question mais c'est une
école de privilégié ou pas c'était le je
voulais rebondir dessus justement ça
tombe bien parce que il faut pas que ça
soit une école qui soit réservée à
certaines catégories et CSP plus on le
voit quand même parce que souvent les
les parents qui ont eu des difficultés
scolaires qui ont des difficultés
financières économiques etc n'oserons
peut-être pas ne pourront peut-être pas
parce que finalement ils pourront pas le
faire et n'oseront pas non plus parce
qu'il prendront pas le risque à ce que
pour eux leurs enfants aillent en
quelque sorte s'amuser alors qu'il
s'amusent pas ils apprennent énormément
mais ils ont le sentiment là aussi à
peut-être l'usine sensation que les
parents pourront avoir de dire moi aussi
l'école particulière en réalité moi je
veux mon enfant ils viennent sur des
apprentissages scolaires un peu plus
traditionnels etc donc il y a deux
freins en réalité il y a le frein
financier je crois que 175 euros ça peut
être un facteur limitant parce que c'est
aussi tout le matériel qu'il y a autour
tout l'accompagnement tout un ensemble
de choses mais au-delà de ce côté
financier je crois que c'est qui est
intéressante parce qu'elle permet de
sortir on l'a pour bien dit à l'instant
permet de sortir de l'école avec
d'autres conceptions pédagogiques alors
parler de deux freins donc moi j'ai deux
questions pour vous Moïse de la vigne la
question de l'argent et la question du
niveau du niveau des élèves est-ce que
vous arrivez
j'adore cette question alors peut-être
l'argent d'abord est-ce que oui ou non
quand même une école de et ben en fait
ça cette question là c'est la question
des écoles alternatives par rapport au
public donc ça c'est pas une question
par rapport au dehors non enfin et donc
la question c'est vraiment dans quelle
mesure on peut s'inspirer ce que disait
Sylvain tout à l'heure dans quelle
mesure on peut s'inspirer de cette
pédagogie de ces pratiques c'est ce qu'a
fait Christelle Ferjou je suis désolé je
reviens à elle mais c'est ce qu'elle a
fait en se disant il y a plein d'écoles
en forêt ailleurs comment je fais dans
ma petite école publique pour mettre
quelque chose en place et pour offrir un
temps régulier d'expérience de nature
aux enfants parce que même dans les deux
c'est pas ils en ont besoin que ça on
peut y arriver on peut tout à fait y
arriver et la preuve il y a dans une
cité éducative Allonnes à côté du Mans
un inspecteur qui a commencé à en parler
et à mettre ça en place dans le cadre de
son projet il a fait un tout petit
accompagnement et donc ça a été validé
par un inspecteur avec un accompagnement
possible auprès des enseignants qui
avaient envie de le faire il y a 80% des
enseignants de cette ville qui s'y sont
mis d'accord et c'est pas et c'était pas
un budget extraordinaire donc c'est tout
à fait possible pour ses parents qui
auraient peur du niveau de leur enfant
alors ça cette question là c'est même
pas seulement une question pour les
enfants c'est pour les parents pardon
c'est aussi une question pour les
enseignants parce qu'une des ouais une
des grandes peurs des enseignants avant
de se lancer c'est ils ont peur des
parents et ils ont aussi peur de pas
apprendre à ces enfants et de pas suivre
le programme etc est-ce qu'on va perdre
notre temps dehors en fait c'est ça la
grande question et en fait ça on a de la
il y a beaucoup de recherches qui ont
déjà été menées parce que les écoles en
forêt c'est nouveau en France mais au
Danemark en Allemagne tout ça fait des
décennies des années que ça existe au
Danemark du business cinquante il y en a
donc des enfants qui ont fait ça
aujourd'hui ils ont 40 ans quoi et donc
on a ce recul là et on sait que c'est
bon pour les apprentissages que c'est
bon pour la réussite scolaire et c'est
notamment sur cette base là que par
exemple en Angleterre ils ont poussé et
ils ont formé vous disiez tout à l'heure
ils ont formé les enseignants pour que
tous les enfants de 0 à 18 ans puissent
apprendre et dans des espaces
d'apprentissage variés dedans et dehors
c'est ça ou c'est la question l'état il
forme l'état il forme les enseignants il
faut prendre cette espèce en compte dans
la formation
en sachant que c'est à peu près 11
élèves ça veut dire qu'actuellement on
sait que c'est autour de 20 un
professeur pour un élève veut dire qu'il
faut doubler le nombre d'enseignants
donc c'est vrai que c'est un vrai choix
politique il faut former les enseignants
en formation continue et en formation
initiale c'est une évolution ce type
d'école là dupliquer ou essayer de la
généraliser parce que j'ai dit tout à
fait oui oui
on pourrait s'imaginer pourquoi pas
parce que de mettre le paquet sur les
premières années de la vie jusqu'à 6 ans
c'est fondamental on le sait tous mettre
le paquet et puis c'est peut-être de
faire une autre type d'école moins
académique plus fonctionnel mais c'est
un coup et puis le coup actuellement
premier budget de l'État l'éducation
nationale 59 milliards d'euros que doute
fort que l'État soit en capacité on va
poursuivre on regarder un deuxième
extrait je vous donnerai la parole
évidemment mais sans calquer exactement
notre modèle sur celui des forêts School
qui est bien particulier on pourrait
effectivement peut-être s'en inspirer
car ce que l'on comprend aussi dans le
film c'est que notre fonctionnement
actuel présente quand même d'énormes
inconvénients nos enfants sont trop
enfermés trop sédentaires trop souvent
devant des écrans et cela fait
évidemment partie des arguments des
défenseurs du modèle écoutez
on estime que en France 4 enfants sur 10
ne jouent pas en extérieur de toute la
semaine ce manque de nature il se
traduit par un certain nombre de
troubles physiques et psychologiques une
absence d'équilibre une baisse des
performances cardiovasculaires un
déficit de vision
se constat-là on le retrouve dans des
rapports de l'éducation nationale qui
attestent du fait que les enfants
souffrent de façon croissante de ce type
de trouble
on est dans l'argument scientifique j'ai
même envie d'idée un problème de santé
publique c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il faut
qu'on revoit notre modèle ne serait-ce
que pour ces raisons là oui tout à fait
je pense que dans ce qui est disque est
important aussi c'est de voir que il y a
eu le contexte quand même il faut le
dire de la crise sanitaire qui a fait
qu'il y a eu un une envie aussi de
sortir et de dire que sortir c'était
symbole de liberté ça je crois que c'est
important et l'autre idée aussi c'est
évidemment de voir autrement aussi
l'éducation parce que c'est quelque
chose aussi qui appartient à notre
histoire je crois dont on a dit là on
dit bon on l'a peut-être un peu plus tôt
oublié mais ce qui s'appelait
l'éducation intégrale ça voulait dire
justement qu'on s'intéressait à la tête
j'ai tout ce qui est intellectuel et
l'école c'est très bien le faire mais
aussi au corps et beaucoup de choses qui
passent par le manuel aussi et puis les
émotions et on s'aperçoit justement que
cette école dehors elle propose cette
éducation plus intégrale on va dire que
celle qui est proposée par un système
plus classique et là vous voyez c'est
pas là c'est pas une question d'argent
c'est vraiment une vision aussi qu'on
peut avoir un peu différente d'un regard
sur l'éducation
des instituteurs et des institutrices
aujourd'hui de l'école publique dans ce
documentaire on a aussi un peu le
sentiment que c'est encore une fois
arrow sur l'école publique comme si
aujourd'hui les instits ne faisaient pas
bien le job on sait bien qu'il y a aussi
des problèmes de moyens mais est-ce
qu'il y a un peu de ça est-ce que c'est
un peu aussi arrow sur l'école actuelle
elle est trop vieille trop classique il
faut pas que ça soit ça là clairement je
pense que si on veut la pérennisation de
l'école dehors il faut justement que ça
passe par l'école publique et je pense
que c'est important c'est le cas mais je
pense ça voilà mais le ça commence pour
moi est important parce qu'on a quelque
part des enseignants qui sont d'accord
mais justement c'est votre question est
très importante parce que effectivement
il faut pas que ça soit cette idée
contre l'école publique c'est l'école
publique qui doit être à mon avis à la
pointe elle peut l'être et j'allais dire
qu'elle a été à certains moments parce
que par exemple même historiquement ce
qu'on appelle la classe promenade qui
est une activité très particulière de
sortir juste avec sa classe et de faire
des activités très concrètes ou les
leçons de choses appartiennent à notre
histoire de l'école publique et donc je
pense que là il y a des choses à
rappeler justement et qui permettent à
un enseignant d'être à la fois humble de
tenter dans ce que ce qui a été dit mais
aussi de se dire que derrière j'allais
dire il y a une aussi une légitimité à
faire cette école parce que là publique
est en train de rater un train quelque
chose un mouvement qui est en train de
se former ailleurs en Europe puis nous
on serait un peu les derniers de la
classe alors on n'est pas en avance ça
c'est sûr on peut se l'avouer par contre
effectivement depuis deux ans depuis le
covid il y a vraiment une prise de
conscience et du côté public et du côté
des médias et du côté politique et des
enseignants aussi qui aussi grâce à la
en fait grâce au contrainte qui a eu
pour le retour à l'école ou tout d'un
coup c'était juste impossible de faire
classe de façon normale tellement il y
avait contrainte mais il y a des
enseignants qui ont commencé à sortir et
des enseignants qui sortaient qui sont
sortis encore plus régulièrement
qu'avant parce que dehors il y avait
moins de contraintes d'espace déjà et on
respire mieux etc donc ça s'est
développé à ce moment là ça acquis de la
légitimité et là par exemple on organise
avec l'association Les Premières
Rencontres internationales de la classe
d'or à Poitiers fin mai et ses
rencontres elles sont sous le haut
patronage du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale donc c'est quelque chose qui
est reconnu qui est validé il y a une
collaboration qui est en train de se
construire tout à fait en complément
j'ajouterai deux éléments la première
par chose qui est en train de sortir
d'une recherche qu'on est en train de
mener auprès des enseignants de
l'éducation nationale qui font classe
dehors depuis un an à trois ans chez ses
enseignants il y a deux choses
intéressantes qui qui émergent la
première c'est la collaboration qui est
qu'il mette en place avec les structures
comme celle de l'école buissonnière donc
du privé pour aller observer apprendre
collaborer avec les personnes et faire
venir leur classe et faire des échanges
donc ça ça je trouvais que c'était très
intéressant justement qu'on sorte de ce
de cette de des cases en fait qu'on
s'auto impose et la deuxième chose que
j'ai trouvé particulièrement
intéressante en particulier sur la les
pratiques des enseignantes et la
formation c'est que de très nombreuses
enseignants qui font classe dehors
aujourd'hui sont des enseignants qui
depuis un certain temps ont dans leur
pratique l'habitude d'être sûr de
l'éducation d'inspiration freinait
Montessori pédagogique classée
alternative mais eux sont en Rep ou
ailleurs dans l'éducation nationale et
finalement il continue dans cette
logique et juste en sortant avec les
élèves et ils donc classe promenade au
départ et puis finissent par faire de la
pédagogie par la nature donc on l'a ce
que j'essaye de mettre en en exercice
qu'on n'est pas sur une rupture mais
vraiment plus en continuum une
continuité
je crois que c'est l'État qui qui
faillit en quelque sorte à sa mission
parce que tout descend tout est
descendant on voit bien que ça descend
du ministère et puis par les recettes
les inspecteurs d'académiques les
IEN etc etc et puis le professeur des
écoles il a des injonctions qui viennent
de en haut et puis n'a pas véritablement
d'autonomie est là ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y a l'autonomie
et ça part de la base et tout ce qui
part de la base concours à un meilleur
fonctionnement et une meilleure approche
en tout cas d'anciennement ou
d'appréhension des problématiques chez
les élèves chez les enfants etc mais je
crois que c'est ça qui est important il
faut être établement en réalité ce sont
les professeurs des écoles avec les
parents avec l'équipe avec les personnes
extérieures qui s'approprient ce projet
ce projet commun qui fait qu'en réalité
ils arrivent vers des objectifs communs
l'objectif commun
de 0 à 6 ans en tout cas la maternelle
c'est quoi la question c'est de dire
quel type d'individu on veut avoir pour
nos sociétés je crois que c'est ça quel
type de d'adulte on veut avoir à partir
de ce moment-là je pense et on les veut
proches de l'environnement et écologiste
c'est pas magique c'est merveilleux ce
qui se passe là parce que c'est on va
former des gens qui seront responsables
à tous les niveaux et qui protège
l'environnement sont les rendre écolos
je pense que la question qui m'avait de
poser aussi c'est vrai que c'est une
question politique c'est une question
beaucoup plus globale parce que c'est
vrai que l'école dehors quand on parle
de la végétalisation justement c'est
aussi des villes alors que ça soit Paris
que ça soit Lille que ça soit
Montpellier mais il y en a plein
d'autres qui ont une vision globale
aussi de penser cette transition
écologique ou en tout cas cette
évolution et l'école dehors ils
participent comme j'allais dire aussi la
place de l'enfant même dans la ville
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi une
question beaucoup plus large certaines
fois qui montrent une vision aussi de
l'individu par rapport à l'environnement
végétal et au-delà du contact avec la
nature ce modèle décolle propose une
pédagogie douce au plus près des besoins
de l'enfant et de son rythme vous me
direz si ça vous semble pertinent dans
un instant mais revoyons ensemble
comment l'institutrice procède avec Maël
par exemple lorsque celui-ci n'est pas
bien réveillé pas tout à fait prêt à
s'intégrer au groupe regardez le moment
du canapé forestier du matin est à un
moment important pour lequel on essaie
d'avoir tous les enfants mais on va pas
traîner un enfant contre sa volonté
timel peut-être des difficultés d'éveil
le matin et donc il a besoin d'un temps
parfois plus long que les autres si on
le force à participer à ce moment là il
va se sentir mal pour le reste de la
journée donc c'est c'est
contre-productif quand on va partir on
espère qu'il sera motivé pour la suite
de la journée
de la vigne on est presque sur du
sur-mesure avec chaque enfant est-ce que
ça doit poser question est-ce que c'est
bien ou est-ce qu'il y a un petit côté
dangereux alors par rapport à ce cas en
particulier je sais pas et moi je suis
pas enseignante en particulier mais ce
que je trouve intéressant dans cette
pratique de classe dehors et donc ce
qu'on peut voir aussi un petit peu dans
le film c'est le fait et même avec des
groupes plus grands c'est quand les 100
plus d'autonomie aux enfants
l'enseignant même avec une classe
entière l'enseignant pourrait être vers
quelque chose de plus individualisé
parce que les enfants seront plus en
groupe amener des activités eux-mêmes et
l'enseignant sera plus dans
l'observation et dans le suivi de chaque
élève et pourra rebondir à ça mais
pardon je répète ma question est-ce
qu'un enseignement plus individualisé
est-ce que c'est si bien que ça quand on
suit on sait que l'enfant devra
s'intégrer un groupe dans une entreprise
avec des contraintes avec un groupe dans
lequel il devra quoi qu'il arrive être
de bonne humeur ou se fondre à un moment
ou un autre vous voyez ce que je veux
dire est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque de
former des individus des futurs
individus trop concentrer sur eux-mêmes
et sur leurs besoins bah après
c'est sûr qu'il faut poser un cadre
après où est-ce qu'on pose le cadre
enfin c'est pas moi qui vais juger tout
de suite mais en tout cas par exemple
dans les écoles en forêt que j'avais
visité au Danemark c'est la grande
question si on se dit mais ces
enfants-là qui sont tout le temps dehors
qui ont tellement de place pour bouger
pour faire du bruit et cetera ça va être
une catastrophe quand ils vont arriver à
l'intérieur et en fait ces enfants ces
écoles en forêt ça fait plus de 50 ans
que ça existe et ses enfants qui se
retrouvent à l'intérieur et ben ça se
passe très bien parce qu'ils sont plus
centrés parce qu'ils ont ils ont
justement ils ont eu ces moments où ils
ont pu bouger et ce qui est intéressant
aussi à l'extérieur moi la première
chose qu'on m'avait dit l'enseignant
dans cette école en forêt au Danemark me
disait l'intérêt d'être en forêt c'est
même pas seulement la forêt c'est que on
a plus de contraintes d'espace on a plus
de contraintes de bruit donc
l'enseignant il a plus besoin de dire à
longueur de journée arrête de bouger
arrête de faire du bruit donc par
rapport à la relation avec l'enseignant
entre l'enseignant et l'enfant ça
améliore la qualité de la relation et ça
c'est quand même la base de l'éducation
c'est la qualité de la relation entre
l'adulte et l'enfant oui et le cadre est
l'autorité aussi Laura Nicolas bien sûr
oui pas tout à fait moi ce que je trouve
intéressant par rapport à la mise en
autonomie de l'enfant et un petit peu
chacun son rythme finalement on se
convoit dans le film ce qu'on voit très
bien c'est la gestion hétérogène du
groupe et c'est même si le mot peut
paraître un peu un peu savant ça fait
quand même partie des programmes des
postures qu'on recommande en tant
qu'enseignant d'avoir un peu cet œil sur
les besoins de chacun de chacune ce qui
est génial en classe dehors c'est qu'on
a la place et le temps pour le faire
c'est à dire que l'enfant peut être dans
son coin en train de faire ce qu'il a
besoin de faire à ce moment-là parce que
par exemple il va avoir des des marrons
ou des châtaignes à côté donc il peut
s'amuser avec pendant que les autres en
même temps et pas non les uns contre les
autres en même temps vous avancer sur
d'autres choses et ce qu'on peut voir
alors ça c'est vraiment par expérience
ce qu'on peut voir c'est qu'à la fin du
fin généralement l'enfant va vers le
groupe on est juste sur des rythmes
différents et pour terminer sur la
notion de cadrage que vous avez posé
elle est très importante et on a
beaucoup de ritualisation on sait à quel
point c'est important pour les petits
enfants les rituels de début la musique
les petits rituels sensoriels de
méditation de yoga on l'envoie dans le
film tout cet ritualisation elle va
poser ce cadre fédérateur dans le groupe
donc même si on a une focalisation sur
l'écoute des besoins des enfants on va
avoir cette ce côté fédérateur quand
même c'est leur Manu il faut s'adapter
au rythme de chaque enfant presque faire
du sur-mesure alors faire du sur-mesure
en tout cas s'adapter au rythme aux
besoins aux intérêts ça je pense qu'il
faut le faire plus je pense que ça
touche aussi quand même les finalités de
l'éducation parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est vrai que notre école fonde d'abord
et pense d'abord à avoir un espèce une
culture commune qui permettra d'avoir
des citoyens
des futurs citoyens libres et
responsables comme il est écrit dans les
programmes mais on voit bien aussi que
l'idée de l'épanouissement de l'individu
et c'est ce que vous avez touché et bien
sûr qu'il y a un risque aussi de
d'autocentrer un petit peu aussi c'est
clair mais il y a aussi la préparation à
être dans une une société c'est vrai que
le terme d'autonomie est pas un gros mot
ça veut dire aussi se connaître soi-même
et mais aussi d'être avec les autres et
c'est vrai que là on touche finalement
des questions extrêmement globales là on
voit bien qu'on demande aussi à l'école
dehors et ce qui est normal d'ailleurs
je pense que pour se pérenniser il va
falloir justement aussi réfléchir à ça
c'est pas simplement je sors voilà c'est
penser aussi à des réflexions globales
parce que comme ça a été dit si on veut
vraiment que ça soit à l'échelle d'un
pays et c'est ce qu'on espère en tout
cas parce que je pense que de toute
façon c'est une nécessité il faut bien
voir que notre lien avec l'extérieur et
avec l'environnement doit changer c'est
clair et ça doit le faire que parler
l'éducation puisque c'est quand même le
seul moyen démocratique de changer une
société donc on voit bien que ça peut
être du long terme mais c'est vrai que
ça peut être aussi du très court terme
c'est pour ça que j'ai appuyé un peu sur
les politiques des collectivités locales
enfin trois mois de le faire mais c'est
vrai que je pense que c'est là que va se
faire les choses parce que justement
c'est un levier extrêmement fort et on
voit bien que on a eu les communes et
les agglomérations j'allais dire un peu
militantes au départ qu'ils ont fait
mais maintenant tout le monde va le
faire parce que justement c'est une
nécessité de réfléchir à notre place
aussi dans l'espace et dans l'espace
urbain puisque nous sommes en très
grande majorité sur la ville donc c'est
vrai que là ça touche des questions de
notre lien évidemment avec le travail
avec les autres et avec les autres aussi
tous les êtres vivants et les êtres
végétaux et qui les encadrent ces écoles
privées je veux dire qui vérifient que
on n'est pas face à des imposteurs de
l'éducation qui qui gère ça est-ce que
l'État a encore la main sur ses écoles
parce qu'elle se développe on a parlé de
l'école Montessori l'école Fresnel
l'école Steiner Waldorf l'école Sudbury
l'école Reggio je veux dire il y a tout
un tas de types d'écoles de modèles
alternatifs qui sont en train de se
développer est-ce qu'on a si les écolos
se Soustra de toute manière l'État a un
droit de regard dessus les enseignants
d'ailleurs sont payés se rémunérés par
l'État donc il y a pas de problème par
rapport à ça les seules écoles qui
posent peut-être parfois problème
parfois problème c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'instruction famille qui a fait peur
m'ont donné au ministre mais
l'instruction en famille aussi un
dispositif qui est intéressant qui peut
être intéressant pour certaines
catégories socio professionnelles mais
je crois que non non l'état rôle l'état
des inspecteurs qui vient et qui
viennent voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur qui vient qui vient de
regarder le contenu en tout cas à la
forme de travail etc évalue et puis
redonne en tout cas le label par la
suite pour pouvoir continuer à perdurer
si on doit conclure cette émission
est-ce que vous êtes optimiste sur le
fait que ce type de modèle est un réel
avenir en France j'entends alors moi je
pense que il y a effectivement plusieurs
modèles possibles mais en tout cas le
fait de prendre en compte l'importance
du dehors dans toutes les écoles qu'elle
soit publique ou privées c'est une
nécessité et on va vers ça et on avance
vers ça et je pense que c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que en plus de la
question de santé publique que vous
parliez qui est un énorme problème et on
sait rien que la question de la
sédentarité sans parler des problèmes
psychiques des enfants etc c'est aussi
un levier très intéressant par rapport à
la question de l'échec scolaire qui est
un gros problème en France c'est
l'inégalité scolaire en France on sait
qu'on est un pays très inégalitaire du
côté de l'éducation c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui dans les résultats pizza on
est vraiment pas bon et par rapport à ça
le fait de varier les espaces
d'apprentissage et d'apprendre aussi
dehors ça permet notamment aux enfants
qui ont plus de difficultés à se faire
une place dans la classe dans le groupe
classe à avoir une meilleure relation
avec l'enseignant et donc c'est encore
plus intéressant pour ces élèves là et
donc de se dire que ça ça peut être un
levier
pour lutter contre l'échec scolaire
c'est pour moi c'est c'est un élément
vraiment très important aussi votre
conclusion Laura Nicolas oui moi j'aime
beaucoup je trouve que la phrase
toute idée réduit révolutionnaire parce
nécessairement par trois phases ridicule
dangereux évident et je trouve comment
on parle de révolution dans le titre de
du documentaire je trouve intéressant de
voir qu'avec la classe dehors on peut
encore passer des fois comme comme vous
l'aviez dit un petit peu un petit peu
bizarre un petit peu surprenant j'ai dit
farfelu parfum j'avais eu lu Berlu dans
la tête ça on peut paraître un peu
farfelu on peut se poser des vraies
questions on en a pas parlé aujourd'hui
mais la gestion du risque est
particulièrement intéressante dans
l'autre dans la maison développée dans
le documentaire d'ailleurs dans le c'est
très bien développer jusqu'à ce que ça
devienne ou que ça redevienne d'une
évidence on parlera de bon sens commun
mais cette école buissonnière c'est
finalement celle de notre enfance quand
on faisait des cabanes et qu'on grimper
dans les arbres donc j'aime bien
envisager cet avenir et la duplicabilité
du modèle finalement
à mon sens apparaître à une évidence
d'ici quelques temps l'évidence de
demain
aux enseignants je pense que c'est aussi
eux qui sont les leviers majeurs je
pense qu'il faut ils sont créatifs ils
sont innovants et je pense que c'est là
aussi où le ministère à son un rôle à
jouer c'est vraiment leur laisser la
main aussi mais je crois que la classe
matérielle à l'intérieur elle est
intéressante mais elle est pas
suffisante parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
stéréotypes dans les classes il y a un
bureau il y a un tableau et un
professeur des écoles etc c'est quelque
chose qui est trop figé à mon avis donc
c'est intéressant mais il faut la
prolonger la classe à l'extérieur je
suis pas sûr que ça soit vraiment une
école buissonnière parce que
buissonnière ça veut dire qu'on fait
rien mais en réalité on fait beaucoup de
choses là donc à mon avis le terme faut
peut-être le changer mais il est il est
important de le faire parce que c'est
autour de ces projets communs qu'on
construit un individu un futur
futur humain et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cet échange merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis comme chaque semaine
sur Public Sénat à très bientôt
[Musique]